here tonight our trump uh trump 2020
campaign senior advisor and maybe the
mvp of that campaign
but laura it's it's back to the future
only we have a different president
were you shocked because i was that the
maoris on every single channel the
homeland security secretary was blaming
president trump for the mess
i mean how absolutely ridiculous
obviously donald trump was the first
person brian to finally call out
remember whenever he announced he was
running for president
this problem no one had addressed it for
so long and donald trump
actually did under donald trump we had
the most secure borders we had
in america in decades so for for anyone
to suggest that this was caused by
donald trump is absolutely ridiculous
i'll tell you who caused it joe biden
when every opportunity he got
leading up to the election he told
people all over the world
if i'm elected president we will have
open borders if i'm elected president
you're going to have free health care if
i'm elected president come
to the united states you don't have to
go through the process
just pour in through our southern border
and that is exactly
what we see happening now it is so
disturbing to see these images and there
is one person to blame
it is joe biden and laura a couple of
things we remember when it happened it
was bad uh for a year and they and
the president fired people moved people
out and got the policy eventually got it
right and mark morgan who worked for
president obama and tom holman who
worked for president obama also
kicked in couldn't go care less about
party affiliation
but then when the first lady went down
to show that she cared
about and had compassion for the
children at the border all anyone talked
about
was her jacket that said i really don't
care uh care
do you but she went down to the border
people talked about
the jacket instead of the first lady
going down to talk to that kid to kids
in the facility do you remember that
oh yeah well it's ridiculous of course
again but
that's how they covered uh our family
that's how they covered the trump
administration
they never wanted to actually focus on
the positive work that was being done
they only wanted to distract with these
ridiculous stories by the way
guess who hasn't gone down to the border
brian joe biden has not gone down
at all he says he's thinking about maybe
going down yet
our first lady melania trump went down
to the border
obviously my father-in-law was down
there all the time
the wall was being constructed it was
you know coming to an
end of to be finished and you see these
sections of wall by the way down there
where the entire wall hundreds of miles
are done and there's a very small
section
where the wall is laying on the ground
all they have to do is put it up
they refuse to do it they are so against
anything donald trump did
but what he did actually worked this
country was safer our borders were
secure
under president donald trump no one can
dispute that well the one thing is
he asked the mexican president he was
working well with president trump and
they look he was a socialist and
everyone said
oh this is going to be problem it was
just the opposite remaining mexico was
forced to go away
quick question about the trump team uh
jason miller yesterday announced that
within the next couple of months you're
going to announce your own social media
i guess infrastructure your own version
of twitter or facebook could you expand
on that
well i don't want to make any premature
announcements obviously what he said
yesterday
uh i'll let speak for itself but look i
think the reality is there are 75
million americans
who feel like they don't have a voice
out there on all of these social media
platforms we are censored
as conservatives and we have seen it
time and time again people are tired of
it
they want a place they can go brian
where they can speak freely they can use
their first amendment rights
so i think what is in store will be very
exciting i'll let my father-in-law or
someone from
the team directly announce when the time
comes for that
but i certainly am looking forward to
something uh where we have
actually have freedom of speech unlike
what we have now on many of these social
media platforms and we saw you
everywhere through your pregnancies go
to bat for
your father-in-law now that you have a
sense of the work-life balance that
would be necessary
does that make you want to run more for
that senate seat in north carolina
well it certainly gives me a sense of
what i'd be in for for
sure having two young kids um it's it's
a big decision and it's a lot to decide
but uh
but it is something that that i'm
considering something that's in the
works so uh
so yeah i think that i got a pretty good
sense of what i would be in for
if i did decide to run for that seat all
right so we'll look forward to getting
that announcement hopefully you'll do it
here
laura trump thanks so much
thank you all right 14 minutes